كانت الفكرة وراء تصميم
جناح uee هي الفكرة التي أردنا فيها
ترميز الصقر الذي
يستريح في عشه
وحماية الجزء الداخلي من المبنى الذي
يمثل الإمارات العربية المتحدة نفسها ، حيث تفتح الأجنحة
وتغلق
مما يسمح بعرض الخلايا الكهروضوئية
والتقاطها  ضوء النهار
لتوليد الطاقة للمبنى نفسه
أيضًا ما تفعله الأجنحة
بالريش الفردي للجناح لدينا 28 ريشة
14 على كلا الجانبين تسمح بالظل
والمأوى للزوار
للحضور والراحة قبل الدخول الفعلي إلى
جناح ue
[موسيقى]
ما فعلناه هو محاولة
وصف شعور خيمة منزل
فرد
من مواطني دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
ومحاولة فعلاً لمحاولة
التقاط خيال الزوار
أثناء تجسيد رمز الإمارات
والمعرض نفسه.  عبر
الرمز المدني الرمزي الذي نراه
أعلاه عند دخولك الجناح ، تنزل
إلى الطوابق السفلية حيث يكون لديك
صورة وحدائق و
كإحساس بالهدوء
قبل أن تدخل المبنى
نفسه فعليًا ، يأخذك عبر
سلسلة من التجارب التي تصف
الإمارات العربية المتحدة نفسها تراثها وماضيها ،
وبعد ذلك ينجذب المرء إلى الفيديو
ويتم رفعه إلى مستوى الأرض
حيث  الانتقال من الماضي
إلى الحاضر ومستقبل الإمارات العربية المتحدة
نفسها ، المواد مثيرة للاهتمام للغاية
لدينا بالطبع الخلايا الكهروضوئية
التي نستخدم فيها مركب الكربون
للأجنحة ونستخدم تقنيات حديثة للغاية
أيضًا من a from a from a
المنظور الأخضر والإيكولوجي ،
المبنى حاصل على شهادة البلاتين ،
وبالتالي
فإن المواد حديثة
للغاية وقابلة لإعادة التدوير بيئيًا للغاية ، لذا فقد تم وضع
كل هذه الأشياء في الاعتبار عند
بناء وتصميم جناح ue
[الموسيقى]